just miles down the road from the
derrick chauvin trial people are
taking to the streets after the fatal
shooting of an unarmed man
police now saying the officer
accidentally pulled out her gun instead
of her taser
law and crime's kim johnson is in
minneapolis and explains how the dante
wright and george floyd cases
have a connection kim
angelica family members of george floyd
have been showing up here
every day in the trial of the former
police officer accused of
killing him but on this day they showed
up for a different purpose
to provide comfort for another grieving
family
who's lost their loved one at the hands
of police
now the floyd family joined dante
wright's family in a press conference
outside the hennepin county courthouse
wright was shot and killed by police
during the traffic stop on sunday
his mom described the last time she
talked to and saw her son
dante put the phone down i heard some
scruffling he got out of the car
and i could hear the police officers and
scruffling with him
then the police officer asked them to
hang up the phone
they hung up the phone three or four
seconds went by tried calling it back to
back to back
because i didn't know what was going on
and i never imagined
this is what was gonna happen i just
thought maybe he was being arrested
and then when i called back the girl
that he had in the car answered the
phone
and it was on a facetime and she said
she was crying and screaming and she
said that they shot him
and she pointed the phone towards the
driver's seat and my son was laying
there
unresponsive that was the last time that
i seen my son
that's the last time i heard from my son
and i have had no explanation
since then
brooklyn center police officer kim
potter allegedly thought that she was
using her taser and not a handgun when
she
shot right she has resigned along with
the city's police chief
the state's bureau of criminal
apprehension is handling
the investigation now civil rights
attorney ben crump is in minneapolis and
is representing the wright family he
said that he
never thought less than a year after
george floyd
died at the hands of police he would be
here again
representing another family and
calling for justice for another black
man who died
in police custody angelica all right kim
and one of the witnesses that the state
called in derrick chauvin's trial
also has a connection to dante wright
tell us about that yeah you may remember
courtney ross she was george floyd's
girlfriend who gave very emotional
testimony
about who george floyd was as a person
well she was here during that press
conference
consoling dante wright's mother
apparently she had taught dante wright
at in high school at edison high school
she came up to his mom
katie wright and said you know every day
i saw
dante in class he always had a smile on
his
face very emotional interaction between
those two
and really what a small world it is that
these two cases
collide in this manner absolutely kim
thanks another story we'll be following
there
when we come back though we'll go back
into the courtroom for the derek chopin
trial
our exclusive legal analysis that you
don't want to miss
is coming up
you